ces pompiers sont déjà sauveteurs
aquatiques
ils participent à une formation
nationale complémentaire au risque
particulier des inondations se mettre à
niveau tout le temps parce que ça évolue
très vite on voit que l'eau c'est pas
notre élément malgré tout donc c'est
bien de toujours manoeuvre et manoeuvré
pour être le plus performant possible
on a des techniques précises et puis ce
qui est bien c'est qu'on a plusieurs
départements ensemble donc du coup on
peut échanger avec d'autres départements
les techniques qui sont à portée pour
lyon et pour l'autre récupérer des
personnes naufragés en danger se créer
une bulle d'air une semaine de stage
théorique et pratique pour 18 pompiers
encadrés par sept formateurs des
compétences nécessaires devant
l'augmentation des inondations le
service départemental d'incendié et de
secours des yvelines a comptabilisé plus
de 24% d'intervention supplémentaire
entre les années 2017 et 2018
le scaphandrier avant et est
principalement engagée dans du secours
subaquatique dans dans des secours en
milieu de 1 aujourd'hui avec le
développement récurrents et permanent
des inondations depuis une dizaine
d'années on est très fréquemment engagé
en fait sur des supports d'inondations
de surface les 10 78 organise deux
stages nationaux par an sur la base
nautique de cergy pontoise dans le val
d'oise dans les yvelines 58 pompiers
sont spécialisés répartis sur 30 centres
de secours les inondations aujourd'hui
sont un vecteur de risque très important
pour les sapeurs pompiers dans leur
engagement
et puis les pompiers soient entraînés et
préparés à ce risque et puis pourront
travailler en sécurité
on est là surtout pour appréhender le
risque et faire attention de savoir à
quel moment on pourra s'engager et à
quel moment il ne faudra surtout pas
qu'on s'engage et on essaiera de trouver
un plan b
enfin pour porter assistance aux
personnes qui sont bloqués
les secouristes yvelinois opère aussi en
dehors du département sur l'année 2017
ils ont réalisé 120 interventions